[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
give me a minute to show you how Cloud
functions empowers you to focus on your
code when getting to production to get
started you'll bring your code in your
preferred and supported language and
runtime as a serverless compute platform
Cloud functions handles everything else
need triggers to kick off your code
provide it automatically for you without
of the Box support for both HTTP
triggers and over 90 event-driven
triggers from gcp services
does your code need to run longer
HTTP triggered functions are perfect for
that as they can take up to 60 Minutes
to complete their work
handling scale is built into the
platform as instances of your code scale
up and down from zero based on demand
you can also now configure each instance
to handle multiple concurrent requests
along with a minimum number of warm
instances that are always ready
Cloud functions even enables you to
perform more complex rollout patterns
such as Canary deployments as you can
now declaratively split traffic between
revisions of your code
and if you're trying to interact with
your other services running in a VPC
Cloud functions enables your code to
securely communicate over a private
Network
so the next time you're looking to get
code running as fast as possible in a
production-ready serverless environment
check out Cloud functions